Have you ever heard your parents say that a penny saved is a penny earned?
Like most kids, I'm sure you're getting the point where you have lots of pennies.
I bet you even have a piggy bank where you keep all your pennies.
And from time to time, daydream about what to spend your pennies on.
I remember my father telling me that money is like toothpaste in a tube.
It's easy to squeeze out and use but almost impossible to put back in.
So before running out and spending your saved money on something that won't last, think twice.
After all, a hundred pennies makes a dollar.
And it takes considerable work to make or save a dollar in today's world.
Make sure you spend your money on things that are important and will last.
This is the first lesson of saving and spending;...
...and often the most difficult to learn.